there have been some genuinely bad
numbers for Donald Trump
since the Ukraine Fiasco started but we
may have gotten the worst one yet
yesterday and it is that North Carolina
Republicans are bailing on Trump since
the Ukraine scandal and the impeachment
inquiry started understand that in the
last nine of ten presidential elections
North Carolina has been strongly
Republican there is a new Meredith poll
where Trump's North Carolina approval is
down to thirty nine point nine percent
now you might hear me say thirty nine
point nine percent and you would
correctly say David that doesn't sound
that low because nationally Donald Trump
has been sort of hovering between 37 and
43 for his entire presidency thirty nine
point nine doesn't seem like a big deal
but understand that this is specifically
North Carolina Trump's Republican
approval in North Carolina is down by
more than 13% from 86 to 74 not 13
percentage points it's down 12
percentage points which is 13 percent
please don't email me about the math
confusion that sometimes happens North
Carolina is the prototypical
center-right but solidly Republican
state which could be a bellwether in
2020 you go back to 1980 North Carolina
has gone to the Republican in the
presidential election every single time
except in 2008 when Barack Obama won it
it was very close in 2016 Trump defeated
Hillary in North Carolina by only three
and a half percentage points in 2016
there already wasn't much of a margin
for error for Trump in North Carolina in
2016
so when you see his support among
Republicans dropping in the state and
driving down the overall approval rating
for Trump in North Carolina you quickly
realized that if these numbers don't
turn around it does not bode
particularly well for Donald Trump so
here's my outlook for the 2020 electoral
college because we often dig into the
polls and we don't necessarily zoom out
and look at what it might mean bigger
picture Donald Trump has been
incorrectly touting that
in 2016 he had some massive
record-setting electoral college win he
didn't but Trump and some other acolytes
are starting to talk about hey you know
what we might win 40
we might win 42 states or more in 2020
now it sounds crazy and it probably is
but there's another side to that coin if
you look back at 2016 Trump won I
believe it's 30 states lots of those
states were razor thin margins and Trump
still lost the popular vote by almost
three million votes Pennsylvania was a
0.7% margin a Florida was a 1.2 percent
margin Michigan was a 0.3 percent margin
Wisconsin was a 0.7 percent margin North
Carolina as I told you was about three
and a half percentage points this could
go the exact opposite way in 2020 and
the Delta meaning the shift from 2016
need only be very small for that to
happen a few percentage point shift in
approval away from Trump in a handful or
even two or three of these key states
such that some Republicans decide to
vote third party some Republicans vote
for a Democrat you don't even need that
many to do that some Republicans choose
to just stay home that could flip three
four or five states easily as a starting
point but once again we can't control
that we need to work on what can we
control which is our turnout if
Republicans help us along because they
either choose to stay home or some will
vote for a Democrat or some of them will
vote third party all the better it just
helps the numbers but when you see these
numbers in North Carolina and you go
back to 2016 and you look at the
razor-thin margins in some states if
Donald Trump cannot maintain or regain
some of this Republican approval in
these key states it is trouble for him
but it is only trouble if we get out and
vote and I apologize I know I'm a broken
record on this but all of this analysis
does not matter if our side doesn't come
out and vote that's just the math of it
and that's why it's so important to
understand that even with low approval
rating if we don't vote Donald Trump can
still get himself reelected send me your
thoughts we are on Facebook at
facebook.com slash David Pakman show we
will take a quick break we do need to
address a lot of you emailed me and that
you said I wouldn't talk about it but
I'm going to Elizabeth Warren has a
toxic racist homophobic surrogate I
talked about Bernie's toxic surrogate
I'm going to talk about Elizabeth
Warren's right after the break I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a 7 day
free trial by going to blankest comm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com /p a que ma n